okay for this week's classic interview
we're going to one that's a little risky
to go back to because we are now the
subject of anger on the behalf of many
of this person's supporters but we
interviewed this guy named H a Goodman
back in January of 2016 he appeared on
the show he said Bernie will win and
Bernie didn't win and then H a Goodman
became a sort of conspiracy theorist
and said a lot of really horrible things
about me which is fine I mean I don't
mind on a personal level but I found
that interesting and we are revisiting
my interview with HJ Goodman today in
the context of Bernie Sanders running
again for president this time for the
20/20 nomination and being as I laid out
for you on Monday I believe the
front-runner if and until Joe Biden
announces Joe Biden the only person
doing better than Bernie in the polls of
course Joe Biden not a declared
candidate so let's get back to my
interview with h.a Goodman from January
of 2016 and sort of think about it in
the context of everything we learned
since I'm joined today by H a Goodman
who is an author columnist journalist
and contributor to The Huffington Post
the hill salon and numerous other
publications based on my understanding
of your recent articles you seem very
sure that Bernie Sanders is not only
going to be the Democratic presidential
candidate but he is also going to be the
next president of the United States it
seems to say it's an optimistic reading
maybe a bit of an understatement I mean
tell us why why you're so sure Bernie is
going to be the next president well when
you look at what he's done David from
last year to today okay so let's let's
let's recap what Bernie Sanders has been
able to do without media coverage are
okay without a super PAC without the
help of the Democratic and National
Committee he went from if you if you
look at polls okay if you think polls
are gospel he went from point
8% in 2004 in late 2014 less than 1%
- now over 40% 40 at 40 41 percent in
one poll because there's a recent poll
that said he's seven points nationally
from Hillary Clinton right that was just
the other day so he did all that in
addition to breaking Barack Obama's
record for it for contribution so he has
2.3 million contributions so he went
from virtually unknown in the polls now
7 points behind Hillary Clinton he has
campaign contributions 2.3 million that
he's at twice the pace now of Barack
Obama in terms of campaign contributions
Hillary Clinton's lead is slipping
faster in 2016 than it did in 2008 and
he's doing all of this with a lot of
media pundits maybe not you maybe not me
maybe that others but a lot of media
pundits saying he can't do it so let's
talk about that a little bit I mean as
far as he can't do it we're fans of
Bernie's on this program I believe that
there there is clearly a path to victory
for Bernie Sanders but it is by no means
a foregone conclusion everything you've
said is true although you you know the
average of recent polls still puts
Bernie Sanders behind Hillary Clinton
nationally by about 15 points but I
think right now the most important sort
of analysis to do is how are things
looking in the first four primary states
right and if we look at Iowa Bernie
Sanders is maybe tied within the margin
of error maybe slightly behind a new
poll has him well ahead in New Hampshire
sort of in an average of revenue
Hampshire polls he's ahead and then when
you look at Nevada and South Carolina
he's behind and very far behind so
there's certainly a path here but when I
read your article saying hey that birdie
is going to be the next president I I'm
not seeing anything that gives me that
level of confidence tell me where I'm
wrong okay so this is why I'm a
maybe I'm the only one but this is why I
think he'll have a commanding I would
not be surprised if he has a dominant
landslide victory and here's why
yeah the primary reason that Hillary
Clinton is up at all the primary reason
is not her record it's not her her
record on racial issues it's not her
record in foreign policy
okay because one leading historian in
the sari story yeah sorry but when
leading a story in in the New York Times
says she'll have a neocon foreign policy
so it's not all these things that record
you can't really you know cite her
experience because she cites the
experience or I couldn't supporters do
but the experience doesn't correlate to
why somebody would say oh this is good
judgment well you're sort of mixing I
think there's two important you know
I'll get you exactly my point
my point is this I believe
wholeheartedly that Bernie will win Iowa
New Hampshire once he wins Iowa and New
Hampshire the floodgates they'll be a
tsunami of media attention once that
media attention takes place that he
didn't receive so he didn't receive
hardly any media attention in terms of
him being able to win him being able to
break the paradigm of Clinton's
inevitability once he gets that media
attention from IU and New Hampshire wins
her aura of inevitability Clinton's aura
of inevitability will be shattered once
that goes and then people start saying
wait a second now let's look at
Clinton's record from a critical
thinking vantage point now pundits are
gonna say wait a second she already has
the e of the FBI investigation
she Bernie's already on her heels right
now when you add in Iowa and New
Hampshire wins and I truly believe
because she already has a southern
firewall that she that she started in
September so back in September the
Clinton campaign already feared Bernie
in Iowa New Hampshire there was so
recently there was an email that said oh
did Hillary Clinton diss the Iowa caucus
and she basically referred to the
Caucasus as creatures of the parties
extremes so she pretty much knows that
and she finished third and ayah 108 so
she pretty much knows that Bernie has a
very very good shot regardless of what
any polls say now and he's already up in
New Hampshire and he's already up in a
couple polls in Iowa but I think that
he'll beat Clinton in Iowa he'll beat
Clinton in New Hampshire once that
happens a tsunami of media attention
he'll win Nevada I surely believe he'll
win South Carolina based on her record
on racial justice issues all right well
you know I mean the fact that you truly
believe that is sort of an interesting
note but in in an effort to stay as
evidence-based here as possible the path
you describe is the path I've outlined
as what would need to happen which is he
can't burn e Sanders comes out after
Iowa and New Hampshire with somewhere
between 45 and 55 percent of the
delegates up to that point from those
Tuesdays and that on the heels of that
he gets momentum going into the second
to the third and fourth primaries rather
but I think that you're there's one
element of your analysis of Hillary
Clinton's lead that is sort of missing
which is I don't disagree with you that
Bernie Sanders is clearly more
progressive than Hillary Clinton
particularly when we look at issues
around banking Wall Street and certainly
foreign policy and there's no doubt also
as we've covered that the Democratic
National Committee in part by scheduling
debates on weekends on holiday weekends
conflicting with big sporting events etc
is working to help Hillary Clinton but I
don't think that's going to be the
deciding factor in the end because there
is no doubt that Hillary Clinton is
number one a very good debater and to
the extent that people hear about Bernie
Sanders is progressive ideas and those
resonate that helps Bernie but Hillary
Clinton has done a very good job of sort
of convincing people by her language in
these debates that she's progressive too
and the name recognition is a big factor
here so while I don't disagree with you
that the path forward is
momentum from the first two primaries I
think you may be overstating the impact
that that is going to have I'm not
saying I hope you're wrong I'm not
saying I hope you're wrong
I just am I don't know that it's this
this a guarantee that you see I could be
I could look I've been wrong in the past
I'm sure I I could be overstating it
you're right like I just think that I I
just think that what Bernie Sanders has
been able to do in terms of achieving
the success he's had is unprecedented
when you don't have a super PAC when you
don't have media coverage and when you
don't have all the advantages that Trump
and Clinton possess I think that once he
wins Iowa New Hampshire I think III
think that he's well positioned to win
both once he wins both I I think that
the media coverage the paradigm by which
she know she's a good debater and all
that stuff it's true she's a good
debater but when when you when you when
you analyze when you look at her record
from a critical thinking vantage point
which I don't think the media does I
think the media will do that after
Bernie wins Iowa New Hampshire I think
of a huge impediment the Sanders
campaign is the belief among many in the
media that he can't win once that once
that is shattered by Iowa New Hampshire
wins I think that that's where my
overall you know thesis lies once he
gets Iowa New Hampshire and I understand
I might be overly optimistic I think
that there's going to be just a tsunami
and not just in the media online and
social media throughout the country
people are already saying hey wait a
second this is amazing
you know Bernie Sanders is really doing
well when he proves that he can win III
think it's going to be a completely new
ballgame all right well that may be and
you know III don't see right now again
evidence based it seems that Bernie's
maybe able to sort of tie in Iowa we're
very very close I don't see any evidence
that suggests he's going to run away
with Iowa in any way but again I don't
think that that's absolutely necessary
for him to have a path to victory we
will start having information about this
very soon and we will check in again
with h.a Goodman and see how his
predictions are doing at that time we've
been speaking with h a goodman author
columnist journalist contributor to any
number of publications h a thanks so
much for talking to us
thank you David thanks for everything